hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Monday morning podcast
from Monday April 16th 2018 what's going
on how how's it going man - dude you're
on the other side of it huh
you paid your taxes you know bum pop it
up up up up up up up up hey take more
than I make who the [ __ ] am i I just did
the [ __ ] job let me give it to you
you rich [ __ ] what are you gonna spend
it on you have a - and douche bag that's
what you know something that's what
really gets my freckles [ __ ] coat
about paying taxes I got no problem
giving these [ __ ] douchebags the
money I get it being a citizen of a of a
country it's like having a membership
all right you want those [ __ ]
potholes filled yeah you want pens and
pencils down at the [ __ ] school you
want the red light and then the green
light did all the light bulbs just
changed you got to pay your [ __ ]
taxes so I don't have a problem with it
the problem I have have though is when
they get more than I get and I did the
[ __ ] job how did you make more of my
gig than I did and I was a guy up there
[ __ ] you know dancing around you know
going down to one knee in the end like
[ __ ] at Elvis as I'm wrapping up singing
his truth is marching on I don't get
that part I mean I do get it I do
understand that you know we have a lot
of expenses in this in this country we
got a lot of expenses you know what I
mean we where we had we got 50 we got a
15 year road trip that was still paying
for right going on 16 years 16 years
with a 16 year [ __ ] road trip I'll
tell what freaked me out I did the rough
and rowdy which was the [ __ ] one of
the great experiences I've had since
getting into the business of
but in the middle of it Dan big cat cats
looked at me and said we just bombed
Syria and my first thought was not like
oh my god were at war because that's
been the natural state for the better
part of two [ __ ] decades my first
[ __ ] thought was how the [ __ ] are we
gonna afford that we're gonna start
another war and how will we go are we
gonna pay for this right this is like
when you watch and your friend at the
blackjack table go and do you got rent
to pay come on it's over cards are cold
let's go back to the room there you know
something you want to buy a house but
fortunately I guess we didn't start a
war this was more like a drive-by you
know we did a drive-by with France as
far as I can tell because you know loved
them before I get in over my head which
I think I already a.m.
I mean is there anything better than
listening to somebody discuss foreign
policy who doesn't even have the decency
to watch the news whatever the [ __ ]
news is now you know I was reading this
article in Rolling Stone oh I read a
little bit this week believe it or not I
read this article in Rolling Stone above
Facebook and the influence that it had
on news like inadvertently in all this
[ __ ] and and how they allegedly have
like when you click on an advertisement
on Facebook like they turned some
[ __ ] camera on and they take a
picture of your face and they try to
read the expression of your face and try
to gauge the level of joy that you have
to determine which ads you're going to
see and the only thing creepier than
that to me is people like do what do I
care you know they're gonna figure out
like what I want to buy
it just is a [ __ ] like human being
that doesn't freak you out that
somewhere you know I know they're not
sitting there looking at it it's some
[ __ ] computer doing it your computer
it's not a person it's an algorithm dude
I don't know I just don't see that any
of this going anywhere good
all right and then they're gonna like in
this [ __ ] unbelievably efficient way
get you to buy something else that you
don't need so then you got to throw
something else out in your house that
then ends up in that swirl of [ __ ]
trash and it's just like it just doesn't
doesn't need to happen so I say that as
I just clicked on something the other
day about ready to buy yet another snare
drum and I'm not even in a band I don't
have any recording sessions coming up I
just I don't know I've been trying to
walk away from it but I I keep thinking
about this snare drum and I add I know I
think a part of the problem well I came
out what the [ __ ] I was gonna look up
why why did we bomb Syria this is this
is how I learned about us okay I'm gonna
click on the first thing the u.s. bombed
to punish it for a chemical attack
that's what I thought u.s. bombing Syria
and Russia's response you know Russia is
in America we act like we used to date
you know what I mean so then we had a
bad breakup so matter what anybody no
matter what they do we look good and
then they do the same thing oh my God
he's so stupid I can't believe I wasted
time getting to know that person during
World War two the United States along
with Britain our Britain was there too
Johnny good show and France bombed Syria
does anybody in England ever say jolly
good show I've been to France like two
or three times that I'd never heard
anybody go halt halt halt
all right bomb Syria on Friday night
Friday night yeah let's let's kick the
weekend off right that's Bob Syria the
decision to strike came one week after
Syrian President Bashar al-assad
that's like a [ __ ] number one draft
pick name like a wide receiver except
for the first thing you know like
tayshaun al-assad dude the guy written
like a [ __ ] 4 140 we just signed him
I'm telling you right now
guaranteed calling you right now put it
on your fantasy team he's gonna get at
least 1500 [ __ ] Y ads this season all
right use chemical weapons against
civilians outside of Damascus I believe
that's the capital killing at least 42
adults and children after that attack
president Donald Trump promised to exact
a big price on the Assad regime the US
and its allies deliberated a response
over the following week what are we
gonna do we gotta uh you want a firebomb
[Music]
economic sanctions we say three to seven
missiles maybe including one on the
outskirts of okay and then on Friday
night the country's hit three targets
including one on the outskirts of
Damascus all related to Syria's chemical
weapons program a research center store
our storage facility and an equipment
facility and command post
wait they said we hit three targets they
just listed three before I mean Research
Center a storage facility and an
equipment facility and command post
oh I don't [ __ ] know the map of Syria
shows the targets hit on Friday the
strikes hit at the very heart of Syria's
chemical weapon program and Delta a
serious blow all right that's [ __ ]
weird man
so we did that and okay and I guess that
makes the world safer
somehow I have no [ __ ] idea I I don't
I don't understand how give but my
babies amaze my here's my question all
right because God knows I don't [ __ ]
pay attention
what if serious somehow poisoned our
food supply or cooked our economy
you know what the [ __ ] weed or started a
heroin epidemic what the in this country
what would we do to them why don't they
do a drive-by on some of these [ __ ]
[ __ ] who are allegedly America
aerelon American citizens what the [ __ ]
they doing here is that ever gonna
happen
[ __ ] no because those [ __ ] donate to
the politicians campaign front so
everything they do it's like it never
happened and then they also advertise on
these gee so-called news networks so
they never talk about this [ __ ] right
but if all freckles goes down and tells
the wrong me2 joke all of a sudden I get
in trouble this is the world we're
living in I'm gonna keep asking
questions my voice will keep going up
higher you know what's serious biggest
problem is it's not that they use
chemical weapons it's that they didn't
buy advertising on CNN Fox before they
did it and donated to the standing
president be he a Democrat or a
Republican and I am saying he because
there's never been a man as president
you know and I'll tell you right now as
long as they keep bringing women around
like [ __ ] Hillary Clinton I don't
think it's ever gonna happen okay you
gotta have some level of warmth to you
you can't come out there with an Al Gore
smile with with the [ __ ] with what
the Mike Dukakis look on your face
thinking that you get you're actually
gonna win it it has nothing to do with
your policy all right you got to come
out there you got to look relaxed you
know you got it you got it you got it
you look like it comfortable
you can't look like you're written way
over your [ __ ] head you know having
that look on your face like do they like
me do they really like me
I don't think there was anything more
Donald Trump's cow was as terrifying is
the Hillary Clinton's that maniacal
[ __ ] smile where was just like I get
like just imagine imagine you're hanging
out with Hillary Clinton and you tell a
joke and then she smiles the way she
[ __ ] smiled you would just be like oh
my god I think this person's gonna bury
an ice pick into the side of my neck and
then Trump it would be over there all I
look at that look on his face I still
can't believe one of them wanted but we
came down to those two but we did but we
did in the comedy ensues I don't mean
why am i talking about foreign policy
for [ __ ] 11 minutes when you know
what I did this weekend I went to
Charlotte North Carolina
all right and I went to the third
installment of the barstool rough and
rowdy tough man competition and I'll say
right and I haven't I don't think I've
had that much fun at any [ __ ] show
business gig since I can remember I want
to thank David Portnoy and dad Katz for
letting me sit there and run my Yap for
four glorious hours over 40 fights dude
somebody would get knocked out and it
was just like get him out of here and
then someone else would go in and every
fight there was a couple of boring ones
but other than that every fight was
great and if it wasn't a great fight it
was a funny fight like when you get to
fatties in there and eventually they
would get gassed and the fight would
just start going into slow motion I
don't know why I didn't think to start
commentating in slow motion like slow my
not slow motion slow my voice down third
rule look Ruth booze might literally
could have talked that slow and kept up
with the action but all right I got to
give a shout out to the the fight there
was three fights to me that
maybe even more than that my top five
fights of the night I would say all
right in no particular order all right I
would say the milkman yes dude went in
his whole pro mode he was dressed as a
milkman drinking milk and was just like
what the [ __ ] does that have to do with
anything and then he gets in the ring
proceeds to beat the [ __ ] out of the
other guy and the guy gets a standing
eight-count if I remember correctly now
don't hold me to this there was over 40
fights and after the staying 8 count
this dude came running across the ring
like Tyson did in his early days when he
threw that overhand right like he was
trying to throw somebody out at the
plate from the warning track and hit
that dude who looked like [ __ ] geese
Osby from the Globetrotters like he
literally thought he killed him this
dude did the same thing ran across the
room except did the unning the
inexplicable he threw an uppercut with
no lead jab nothing to set it up
I sell Buster Douglas dude at one time
he got half we led with an uppercut and
got drilled in the face and that was it
the night was over I'll never forget
this guy goes you never lead with an
uppercut well the milkman proved that
theory wrong he ran across he did a
running uppercut if I remember correctly
and just knocked this guy the [ __ ] out
and then I understood why he was called
the milkman because the milkman always
delivers isn't that a nice story it was
a great story and in there there was
head trauma
somewhere in that story that was head
trauma all right then the dude who came
in after the main event dressed as the
pink Power Ranger this guy went in
dressed as a pink Power Ranger 5 foot
nothing a pink onesie on with little red
sneakers like the kind of sneakers that
you know people who embrace being a nerd
wear now and for some reason they don't
get the [ __ ] kicked out of them like
they did when I was a kid instead they
get glorified you know his nerd power
whatever so he goes in there dressed as
the pink Power Ranger and proceeds to
take like 19 or 20 jabs to the
[ __ ] nose until he's bleeding just
basically got his face red he didn't get
the [ __ ] kicked out of him but he got
[ __ ] knocked around so at the end of
the fight
the post-interview fight he's standing
there with his nose [ __ ] bleeding i
just shy of profusely and they're doing
the interview and they said we got asked
why did you come in dresses to pink
Power Ranger I'm sorry I don't know the
character's name why did you come in
dresses to pink Power Ranger and the guy
just what the straight face just goes
cuz she's a badass [ __ ] I [ __ ] her any
day of the week I don't know if the kid
understood how funny if he knew
understood how funny what he just said
was the way he delivered it I would say
that that's the next great comedic mind
in Hollywood because it was very Andy
Kaufman stabbed he knows bleeding and
the way he said I'd [ __ ] her any day of
the week he said it like the actress
that plays that pink Power Ranger would
be thrilled with that opportunity like
oh my god I could [ __ ] this guy any day
of the week mow up the whole window of
opportunity just open I to the point I'm
almost dizzy with my new options the
thrill ride against the Bavarian
Hungarian the German versus the American
which all night long people were in the
building chanting USA USA any time
anybody came in if you wore sweatpants
if he had on a sports bra or whatever
the [ __ ] you had a bandana anything that
had Old Glory on it people would start
chanting USA USA even if the other
opponent was also from the United States
of America a thrower I lost a unanimous
decision I thought it should have been a
split decision but he fought a great
fight and the German won just a [ __ ]
monster of a man that was a great fight
and and then lastly was the frat boy
versus the blue collar kid and you know
you think the blue collar kids gonna
[ __ ] come in they're just like the
Hollywood movie and sure
this rich so-and-so you know what a
[ __ ] knuckle sandwich tastes like or
whatever the fight and that's not what
happened the phret frat boy kicked the
[ __ ] out of the guy like the guy had no
[ __ ] answers and then he [ __ ] the
frat boy threw a left and he must have
missed and he separated his shoulder it
looked like and then he grabbed his
shoulder and it back up and they got the
video he popped it back in himself
like [ __ ] Mel Gibson in lethal weapon
and he wanted to continue but the ref
was like you can't continue so then the
blue-collar guy won yeah I don't even
think I don't know if he even landed a
punch so in the post fight the frat boy
is [ __ ] pissed he's got all his frat
buddies there in the blue collar guy
talked all this [ __ ] oh yeah you're
bringing all your frat buddies where
they're not gonna be in the ring to save
you it's just gonna be you and me and
I'm gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you well
the frat kid didn't need all his friends
we beat the [ __ ] out of that guy and and
the post-fight they were interview when
the frat kick goes it's a tough loss and
the frat kids go and I didn't lose I
beat the [ __ ] out of him which was true
and and then the interviewer just kept
going yeah but you know he but you lost
yeah but you lost he kept going yet but
you lost and I saw at one point the frat
kid consider punching the interviewer in
the face and I was actually nervous for
the interviewer thank God the frat kid
didn't do that and then a special
mention would be the guy who came in he
looked like an angry version of the lead
singer from maroon 5 and he came in and
in the first round did not throw one
punch just put his gloves up on either
side of his head and we were like what
the [ __ ] this is like like ELF resin
like he was getting upset you know like
when Dana White gets mad because someone
doesn't put on a fight the crowd was
booing and all of his [ __ ] and then he
comes out for the second round and he
kind of looked over in our general
direction but not quite at us smiled and
winked
and I said oh [ __ ] he's doing the
rope-a-dope he just let this guy rockem
sockem and tire himself out and then he
went back out there and started doing
the same thing again I'm like what the
[ __ ] is he doing but then eventually he
started throwing punches at that 3-1
minute rounds and by the third round you
know he'd thrown quite a few punches and
landed quite a few but I still I thought
the other guy was a clear victory for
him and the judges came back and they
gave it to the maroon 5 guy so there's a
little bit of controversy but um anyways
when I was sitting in a [ __ ] rig site
about ready to announce boxing matches
you know this is something that I
actually it's one point in my life I
wanted to be a sports announcer and
before I realized that it was a lot of
work and I had no idea how to do it so I
just was like well I kind of get in
trouble for making jokes I'll just
become a comedian how about that well I
was sitting in that that [ __ ] ring
the Civic Center there whatever the hell
it was and it looked like early a the
crowd looked like an early 80's
wrestling crowd and when they all
started chanting USA USA I was just like
this is so [ __ ] surreal right now to
be with this level of stupidity to be
sitting in the middle of this I had like
this is the type of [ __ ] I'm not saying
that I'm smarter than these people all
right I just haven't been around that
level of stupidity since I was the
average age of the person in the crowd
and I would go to an event like that and
I would chant USA USA would you like my
credits I went to a live taping of
Morton Downey jr. show and it was
screaming and yelling and standing up
and applauding I saw Dice Clay in 88 at
the Worcester Centrum and and with the
crowd we all tried to boo the opening
act offstage i booed another stand-up
comedian before I was a comedian and
karma came back to bit bite me in the
ass you know when I [ __ ] did that
Philly show so I've been there and to be
an event like that a tough man event
when everybody was chanting USA USA was
so [ __ ] surreal and I just pictured
all these [ __ ] you know all these
liberal people [ __ ] being disgusted
with it and it just struck me as really
funny and I don't know it took me back
to haven't thought it but I actually had
to look the guys name up unfortunately
Morton Downey jr. I couldn't remember
his [ __ ] name which is another reason
why I'm so happy I got married and had a
kid because that guy was so goddamn
famous and I was such a huge fan of his
and somewhere in the back of my closet I
still have a sweatshirt from that going
to the Morton Downey jr. show I got that
I got of this is what I did in the 80s I
went to that I have a bud man hoodie do
you remember when they they used to have
a superhero for Budweiser I have that
and I have a Stevie Ray Vaughan tank top
I didn't get the t-shirt I got the tank
top because it was the 80s and I wanted
to show off my pasty guns you know cuz
nobody did squats everybody just did
upper body in the 80s from the instep
tour that's what I have left from the
[ __ ] 80s but anyways that came where
the [ __ ] I was going with that but it
was it was amazing and I want to go back
to that venue and I want to do a
stand-up show in the round in the middle
of it that's how much I enjoyed
performing there I mean actually
announcing that's how much I enjoyed the
arena so I want to thank everybody that
came out once again thanks to everybody
at barstool if they'll have me again
I would absolutely in a heartbeat I
would I would I would do it again cuz
that was just my first one and I think I
was funny but I think I could be a lot
funnier I just had to there was just a
lot of [ __ ] to take in it's like what do
I do it do I actually announce the fight
I don't know [ __ ] about fighting right
do I just try to be funny and then I
also had to figure out how you know Dan
and Dave worked so I wouldn't be in the
[ __ ] way so I kind of
I thought towards the end got funnier so
who will see we'll see if I get in if I
get another shuttled I would definitely
do it and you guys she got a fine you
know I want to thank everybody that
ordered it too because I think they I
think that was their best one as far as
as far as what I heard
anyways let me read a little bit of
advertising here dollarshaveclub.com
everybody Oh get rid all that junk
that's lying around your bathroom you
[ __ ] lunatic give it the cleaning it
deserves and then freshen up with
high-quality products from Dollar Shave
Club Dollar Shave Club members you know
what you can get it well you can get
everything you need delivered right to
your [ __ ] door Dollar Shave Club has
razors shave butter shampoo for your
pubes body wash
toothpaste everything you need to look
smell and feel your best you'll get an
amazing high-quality shave every morning
using Dollar Shave club's executive
there dr. Carvey's ez shave goes on
clear so you can see where your shaving
can somebody please explain that detail
to me it goes on clear so it's
see-through
so you can somehow see where you're
shaving maybe it's shiny does it glisten
anyways and since Dollar Shave Club
delivers everything to you yeah it out
after set foot in a store wandering the
aisles hunting for razors getting caught
looking at some soccer moms tits you
know gotta look for shampoo what aisle
is the body wash in where the hell's the
toothpaste he can take all of that and
throw it away
none of it clean up your bathroom and
your morning routine with Dollar Shave
club's daily essential status set for
just five dollars with free shipping
you'll get the six blade executive razor
plus trial sizes of this shape body
cleanser and one white cherry oh then
keep the blades coming for a few bucks a
month speaking of next month for a
limited time only used code burr be you
are are at the checkout to get five
dollars off your second month of the
club
that's cold burr at dollarshaveclub.com
to say five dollars off your second
month join the club
to davia and lastly but not leastly our
old friends the cornerstone
cornerstone of the advertising here on
the podcast
stamps.com stance comm saves you time
and money which you can use to grow your
business I can mail any letter any
package using just my computer and my
printer and the mail mail carrier picks
it up they switch that from mailman
needs to be a mailman and I'm sure some
woman who walks the beat or drives a
Jeep bitched hey I'm out there too just
to let you know sorry sweetheart
I'm not your sweetheart whatever the
[ __ ] I have to say to end the
conversation sugar tits mail the mail
person
the mail carrier patient number one
picks up everything from postcards to
envelopes to packages domestic or
international create your stamps calm
accountant minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no long term
commitments click print mail and you're
done that's it oh it's so convenient
good lord is it easy
you know it's reliable and dare I say
efficient I used all the adjectives they
wanted me to use stamps calm will even
help you decide the best place that's
class of mail based on your needs I use
stamps calm when I write whenever I send
out my poster which by the way I'm
taking the photo today for my tour which
is simply called 50 you know why cuz I'm
a rap fan no because I'm turning 50 in
June I'm gonna send out all my posters I
use stamps calm when I can do when I do
it I am a [ __ ] if I can do it so can
you
alright I don't care how many math
classes you flunked like me there's no
math involved and right now you too can
enjoy it you just take the thing you put
it on the scale it figures out what it
weighs then you type in your stupid the
zip code it's going to and magically it
gives you the answer it's like sitting
next to a smart kid that's not covering
up his [ __ ] test and right now you
too can enjoy the stamps.com service
with a special offer that includes a
four week trial plus postage and a
digital scale go to stamps com click on
the microphone at the top of the
homepage and type in bird that's
dance commenter burr do you member when
you try to look at some smart kids
[ __ ] test and he cover it up you know
and you get mad at him cuz they did the
[ __ ] work I don't know where I stand
with that I used to hate it when I was
in school but now when I think about it
the fact that that person did the work
and then I just want to show up they
mean it very the very least I could have
offered the kids something like hey I'll
buy I'll buy an extra bag of chips at
lunch or some [ __ ] you know what I mean
or whatever the [ __ ] you want whatever
whatever whatever they used to sell
there right and all the junk food that's
all they had was junk food they had a
shitty meal and then they had it was
like cookies potato chips just a bunch
of [ __ ] and I remember like full lunch
sometimes if I didn't like the lunch I
would just take my lunch money and I
would buy all junk food and people would
say dude you got to get a bunch of zits
if you eat like that and I was like I
don't think I'm gonna you know what am I
gonna do have an apple and then get
bullied he's eating an apple
you know insert homophobic [ __ ] after
that alright let's talk some sports here
I know this is a weird time for most
people in most cities your hockey team
and your basketball team are done for
the year and now you're looking at your
baseball team but when you live in the
city of Champions or at least you were
from there and nobody wanted
championship until you left like me well
the Celtics do and the Bruins went to
when I was a little kid and I don't
remember although I did have this little
Bobby Orr sweatshirt
my mother saves everything I got to find
that thing oh my god that would be great
find that thing put it on my cute little
daughter take a picture oh god I got to
find that anyways if you live in a city
of Champions not only did your
basketball team with 17 championships
win it your hockey team with six Stanley
Cups also won it well I mean made it to
the playoffs let's start let's
with the Boston Bruins they're up two
games to none against the original six
Toronto Maple Leafs who are trying
desperately to end a 51 year drought I
am a fan of the Toronto Maple Leafs if
the Toronto Maple Leafs get biased I
will root for them okay I would like the
suffering to end in Toronto all right
I would also like us to beat them I want
us to beat them first however if they do
beat us then that will be my team all
right
having said that you got your asses
we're in the first two games of this
series I mean just it was easy i mean i
i'm not gonna say was the first two
periods of game two were a little [ __ ] a
little scary and period one of the first
game you know that 51 when he did that
that [ __ ] slap shot from the [ __ ]
blue line that Laza that hit the
crossbar I was thinking like this game
can turn in any second and I kind of
felt that way for a lot of the second
game it just never did because we have a
guy named David posture knock on our
team who's I I would say at this point
is just shy of becoming a superstar
the guy's got nine points in two games
he's making it's so ridiculously easy he
[ __ ] scored the last goal he put the
puck between his legs like he was
[ __ ] around before the game right
they shouldn't gloat are amusing that's
the second Globetrotter [ __ ]
reference in the same podcast within a
half-hour 31 minutes 32 minutes excuse
me if you find another podcast out there
that's gonna bring up geese Osby and
then swing then [ __ ] in a falsetto
voice getting the talk right now sing
Sweet Georgia Brown huh you tell me you
tell me you show me a podcast that does
that and I want to show you a more
successful podcast in this one nine
points that whole [ __ ] line a [ __ ]
burger odd mash on posture knock and
we're playing great defense toukas but
you know making some incredible saves
you can tell right now that I haven't
watched a lot of games this year all I
know is that at the front
the Boston Bruins has not gotten the
credit they deserve for the incredible
rebuild that they did at this team they
got rid of everybody oh look who's here
hi what oh okay oh so then what I have
to watch my beautiful little baby girl
Oh boohoo
oh poor me alright no worries
yeah alright buddy alright anyways okay
bye-bye I just gotta wait till she
leaves I don't see any bad words and
further anyway so the back in ruins we
got rid of like the whole [ __ ] team
basically other than Chara Marshawn and
Bergeron essentially as far as our big
stars we got rid of Johnny Boychuk Milan
Lucic Tyler Seguin dougie Hamilton Tim
Thomas we can get rid of the coach khlo
Julian we got rid of everybody and I was
thinking like wow alright I tried to put
a positive you know spin on it I like
watching a rebuild and all that stuff
which I was I watched him all this time
until this year when it all came
together you know but I have a good
excuse you know got the kid what am I
supposed to do huh not go out there and
play with my kid course I got to do that
but um I don't know we're like really
young we're really fast and then we
still have some veterans and then we got
some other guys that have you know yeah
we got some like guys that have been
playing like six seven years it's just
this great mix and then all these young
kids that are just flying around the
[ __ ] ice and I don't know what we're
gonna do this year and the playoffs
that's looking good so far but I am like
in the future and speaking about the few
speaking of the future the Boston
Celtics that's what you're watching
that's out on the court because
everybody's [ __ ] hurt Kyrie Irving's
out Marcus smart so you know I told
we forgot about that Gordon hey what kid
played [ __ ] half a quarter this year
he's coming back next year so I'm just
watching the Celtics this year just to
see like as far as the playoffs to see
like tatum Rozier Jalen Brown all of
these guys getting all this this just
quality minutes in the playoffs it's
just gonna help us in the future and you
know III don't think that we were gonna
get by Cleveland or even Toronto Toronto
looks unbelievable but my favorite thing
in the NBA playoffs right now is the
name of the Milwaukee Bucks coach Jill
Prunty
I swear to God every time they say it
that's like that they just say kunti and
I don't know why but if there was a
drinking game that every time they said
Joe Prunty in the broadcast that I
watched I would have been shit-faced by
the end of the first quarter
Joe Prunty I guess what's-his-face
I can't remember his [ __ ] name either
Jason Kidd I don't know what happened to
him he was there I don't know why he's
not there and it's gonna be great to
watch I don't know how many games
against the Bucs in Giannis
antetokounmpo sorry see I'll take the
Ocampo let me actually you know what let
me can we get the proper pronunciation
of that that was a [ __ ] great game I
mean it's it's you can't as a Celtics
fan not be disappointed when you're
watching it seeing all our big guns on
the bench being like we would be kicking
the [ __ ] out of this [ __ ] team if
everybody was healthy
Yanis on I'll take two cumple but yeah
you say this guy's [ __ ] name
pronunciation what a show pronunciation
here we go alright
Oh Yanis himself is going to explain
here we go come on now my internet sucks
wait you gotta say with a deep
compo but in the Greek way you say with
the NC like answer to Kanpur so I change
myself like after this way you say the
last name whatever you whatever you got
just say no it's the answer to come pop
Janna started to come home
Cantus young Giannis antetokounmpo you
can say with the T of the D you gotta
love that the guy has that difficult
last name and I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] I'm just gonna be
dominating the game that's another thing
too was I get to watch this guy for a
number of games to who I think he might
be the next one you know once LeBron if
LeBron ever gets old I would say this
guy's gonna be the next one it's gonna
be well maybe it'll be Kevin Durant and
then him as far as like the best guy in
the league and I'm saying that having
not really I don't really know [ __ ]
about hoop you know that [ __ ] why do
you guys listeners I don't know [ __ ]
about boxing I'm commentating about it I
don't know [ __ ] about foreign policy yet
I'm talking about that asking why we're
not having missile strikes on
corporations all right hippy music let's
do some Reed's here for the week we're
gonna do a couple of Reed's here for the
week oh by the way I have to admit I got
a I got to become Jimmy Swaggart if
Billy Swaggart as far as my remember I
said I was gonna be vice free 16 days
and actually the final two days in March
is when I started this but I said I was
gonna be vice free I got to go a little
Jimmy Swaggart here I have sinned
against you I [ __ ] up Saturday night I
went out with my way and we went out to
go see some live music at this little
Club slash dive bar that we really loved
going to and we went there and he was
like come on me you're not gonna have a
drink you're not gonna have a drink and
I'm like no you know I told my podcast
listeners I was gonna blow a blood she's
like come on
yeah what [ __ ] drink I said fine
you want me I'm [ __ ] I was really
annoyed with her because I realized how
weak I was you let me have [ __ ] taken
a [ __ ] drink right so I ordered some
food and then I had a quarter to club
soda with the lime and then I was just
like if she doesn't bring up having a
drink again I'm not gonna order one all
right
I don't want to throw away all these
days right so she finally just goes look
can you just have a hit of weed or
something like that I was like I don't
[ __ ] like weed or whatever and she
just I just find said [ __ ] it I'll do it
so I went outside the place and I took
four hits off of this [ __ ] joint and
I hate weed I just don't [ __ ] like it
and I go inside and what happens every
time I smoke weed is I just get sleepy
and I want to go to bed so I'm watching
this amazing band incredibly musicians
and they could also sing too which is a
plus they sounded like I like out like
you were listening to a record they were
so good and they ended up doing a cover
of Led Zeppelin since I've been loving
you that Led Zepplin would have been
proud of and I'm sitting there in the
corner of the bar being like hey man I
just want to go to bed man like you know
I think my pillows like my best friend
man and I just you know so so I blew it
but you know what I didn't drink and
yesterday was the big test because now
that I [ __ ] up the whole month I feel
I'm just like well well now what so now
do I drink so last night I was thinking
I might as well have a [ __ ] drink as
I blew it I said I don't be a [ __ ] he
had a couple of hits of [ __ ] weed he
didn't enjoy it then he came home and
you went to bed so whatever I hit one
hurdle
all right I've jumped over all the other
ones and I'm gonna keep going plus I was
also sober for the last two days of
March so but I still didn't make a month
then I basically made was that two days
ago 14 I went 16 days I don't give a
[ __ ] I'm gonna keep [ __ ] going so
whatever
I blew it I blew it man I gave in to
peer pressure from my wife you know she
always ends up knocking me off the wagon
though number one time I went a year in
two days without booze and we were we
were in no
away if this fancy [ __ ] restaurant
and it had like a foot like a 12-course
meal all these little bytes kept coming
out I was just laughing going we're
never gonna get full and by the eighth
one I was like wow I think I'm gonna
puke and they just kept coming and then
the end they came out with this cheese
plate for dessert that's when you know
you're a ritzy [ __ ] place in another
country dessert is cheese it's like you
eat cheese for dessert really and it was
this pungent stings the nostrils
anchorman level [ __ ] Cologne but it
was cheese and Nia took one bite was
like I can't [ __ ] no way so I started
taking giant bites out of it
and she was going cut out don't don't
you're gonna get sick in my eyes were
watering my nose was running but her
reaction how concerned she was for me
was making me laugh so hard that I ate
the whole [ __ ] cheese plate and it
was it was [ __ ] disgusting but in that
meal she knocked me off the wagon she's
done it to me a number of times what I'm
trying to say is that I'm Sid and she's
Nancy but I won't kill her someday
so anyways but I have to admit that I
really like you know the mornings are
the best I wake up I feel good I work
out you know then just four hits a weed
the next morning I woke up I felt like
[ __ ] I just felt like I needed to
squeegee my goddamn brain so I don't
know maybe she reminded me why I'm doing
this so I think I'm gonna do this right
through to my birthday and then I'm
gonna be on vacation everybody I'm doing
I'm doing a show in Dublin Ireland and
then I'm doing Royal Albert Hall in
which I can't believe in London England
and then then I'm on vacation and for
the next ten days or whatever if I want
to drink I'm gonna drink if I want to
smoke a cigar here or there I'm gonna do
that and then when I come back I think
I'm gonna jump right back on the wagon
I'm gonna try it that's that's what I'm
gonna try to do because I'm eating well
and I'm keeping the weight off and who's
kidding who I became a dad real late in
life and I'd like to
be around so I got to shut down the
potty a little bit alright that's
another great thing about having a kid
if I didn't have a kid I probably would
would have shaved a good 15 years of my
life
oh what a fun time I would have
alright let's read some let's read some
of the some of them use some of the
music
Oh hippy music that's why I said music
some of the questions here for this week
by the way did anybody see the Andre the
Giant
speaking of civics the Andre the Giant
documentary you got to check it out you
got to check that out my favorite part
was I guess in the locker room the only
thing they allowed in the locker room
were wrestlers and in the referees no
one else was allowed in there and he
would and Andre would always be in there
playing cards and what I loved was that
one they actually had footage of
somebody walking in there with a camera
and Andre the Giant standing up just
going goddamn Bigfoot that's when he had
the fro he stood up and the person just
ran out with the camera that was my
favorite [ __ ] part seeing a giant
angry usually it's a gentle giant but
actually seeing him [ __ ] upset
sorry alright guys sorry about that I'm
supposed to [ __ ] liven up your week
now making you want to put your head
down in your desk
alright hippie music blind-spot
follow-up not original writer a Billy
read tits
so your first Cincinnati show with two
friends last Saturday you absolutely
killed prime bur this is why you're the
greatest living comedian that nice he
said okay let me take let me take your
dick out of my mouth why do guys always
feel like you know they get all [ __ ]
homophobic out if they compliment
another man they always have to say hey
man yeah that's a nice shirt no homo
it's just like well dude I've known you
for 20 years I would think if you would
have [ __ ] made a move at this
point you know you could just say nice
shirt as per the most recent Monday
morning podcasts I'm writing to second
John Fishman of fish as a drummer you
need to pay attention to you asked for
start alright this is it I'm gonna
[ __ ] get into fish you asked for
starter albums I submit a live release
you should start with live double album
a live one or a studio circa 1993 rift
rift is my favorite album it's a concept
album
oh I write I'm you know what I'm doing
right now I'm [ __ ] I'm gonna download
it right now so I don't forget all right
here we go
iTunes store I'm old I know you guys all
use a cooler [ __ ] downloading site
all right fish with the pH RI f T let's
see if I can get it where is it where is
it
rift 999 BAM clicked by downloading all
right there we go I took your advice
all right a picture of nectars another
good one would be my second favorite
covers of all genres include covers all
genres including jazz country Calypso
rock and roll in neo psyckadeli amman
according to Wikipedia I can't listen to
psychedelic music because there's a
small part of me that really wants to
try mushrooms and when I get in when I
listen to that music I always think like
how much more intense would this be if I
felt like I could hold my brain in my
hand named for nectar you know but I'll
never do psychedelics because you have
to be home when you do it but now I got
a kid so I can't I can't be tripping
with a kid I can't do that that's when
social services comes by and takes you
[ __ ] kid named for nectars bar in
Burlington Vermont that's what the
album's named after where they were the
house band starting off their careers
anyway love your [ __ ] and psyched to
hear your thoughts on John Fishman fish
drumming to me they belong in music
history books but would love to get
Billy rowdy Reds take on it signed from
Kentucky all right cool oh I love I
already love the title
this one here why I need an ar-15 all
right all you Hollywood liberals listen
up I asked people in the middle of the
country or just outside of Los Angeles
which a lot of people in LA specifically
Hollywood consider in the middle of
[ __ ] nowhere right until they have a
movie premiere and then they go down
there we love you from Bakersfield okay
why I need an ar-15 I just listened to
you talk about not knowing why anyone
would need an ar-15 I didn't say that in
an insulting way you country [ __ ] all
right I'm just saying you know what I
mean if like you know for home defense
it's just funny to me it's just like how
much of an [ __ ] are you that you need
an ar-15 for home defense that basically
on it you're such a [ __ ] that on any
given night that [ __ ] hit squad from
that the end of Scarface is going to
come over your [ __ ] fence that you
need to mow em down you need to
basically you know [ __ ] bazooka
anyways the reason I need an ar-15 is
because I have a small flock of sheep
and I live in coyote country coyotes you
live in Phoenix coyote won't really
coyotes won't really harm an animal as
big as a cow but sheep or goats are fair
game to them when coyotes attack in
packs they tend to attack in groups of
seven to twelve individuals Jesus Christ
the [ __ ] do you live we have coyotes out
here they usually in packs of two's even
though I am that's because they're all
in some Hollywood diet most of them died
of anorexia
so there's packs of two's even though I
am a fairly good shot trying to hit a
moving target without hitting my sheep
means that I might miss several times I
need the magazine capacity of the ar-15
or a similar gun because I only have for
milking use so how you say it
use what is a ute w es yeah jesus
[ __ ] christ I mean this is an easy
one but I'm not a farmer man use pro
none CH pronunciation what a sho
pronunciation
here we go here's how you say it come on
you you you didn't need to do it three
times
how [ __ ] dumb I am I you how do you
say you Y you oh you all right you you
you okay he did a subtle different read
on the second one you you oh god what's
happening now
Oh fifty word mistakes in this lesson I
will show you fifty words that you are
probably pronouncing you correctly right
now and I'll also teach you how to save
them
oh I thought you just using how to say
I'm wrong you how do you say it well we
say pronounce pronounced and pronouncing
but pronunciation there's no noun in
this word it's pronunciation nobody says
pronunciation you [ __ ] clickbait [ __ ]
cat
there's no aughh in there it's cat all
right why I need an ar-15 okay so these
coyotes come down in packs of seven to
twelve oh my god and his use use use our
[ __ ] running around man I mean what a
[ __ ] exciting morning Jesus Christ
that's like the ultimate video game so
then you [ __ ] blow these things away
and then what do you feed them to the
pigs I mean that is it you know these
these [ __ ] [ __ ]
CrossFit running down the [ __ ] Street
like they doing something this guy is
inside watching deputy Dawg you know
Babbitt bap
[Music]
right and all of a sudden here's one of
his use going in he's got to come out
there with this [ __ ] machine-gun get
some get some get some I'll tell you
this right now find if I could [ __ ]
rent a helicopter big enough and I can
we could open a door and you could
[ __ ] shoot him from up there I would
fly you around your own property sir
while you did this with your [ __ ]
ar-15 anyways I need a magazine capacity
of eight of the ar-15 or similar gun
because I only have four milking use use
use and I produced feta and Parmesan
cheese what a good [ __ ] I love both of
those cheeses thank you for producing
that so I can eat it if I lose a single
you you you that represents a
significant percentage of my income for
the year my that's you know all these
Hollywood liberals I swear to God if you
stole their [ __ ] yoga mat or
threatened to cut off their [ __ ] man
bun yeah I bet every one of them get a
[ __ ] ar-15 but they put pink bullets
in it
my sheepdog can hold the Coyotes off for
a little while but not forever
that's a [ __ ] that dogs got heart huh
holding off 12 [ __ ] coyotes that's
like when Magic Johnson played every
position other other farmers in more
western states need the ar-15 to protect
from mountain lions or wolves so when
someone said no one needs an ar-15 I
guess they think that I'm nobody
you're a somebody you make the cheese
why don't you have to go that route you
proved your point
and now you're trying to make everybody
feel bad for you oh well I am somebody
this is hilarious it's like self-help I
guess they think that I'm nobody
I am somebody and I have a legitimate
need for an ar-15
oh let's clap round of applause that was
just textbook
how what's he supposed to do let those
yous get killed and then little kids
can't put Parmesan cheese on their
[ __ ] rigatoni God bless you sir god
bless you your ar-15 and the wonderful
cheese you make what do you do with all
the dead coyotes oh man this guy's they
met that's [ __ ] living out there I
mean the first one the first one yelped
when you [ __ ] shot it I would feel
like an [ __ ] however though I would
know good and goddamn well that if I
didn't make the cheese then I would be
living outside next thing you know those
pack of seven to twelve would be coming
at me right gonna take a [ __ ] bite
out of my flat [ __ ] freckled pasty
behind can't have that good for you sir
I'm glad they've invented a weapon so
you can keep making the cheese and you
can afford to keep you know paying the
banker [ __ ] god bless you I'm convinced
all right girl it that's a great [ __ ]
argument that argument is nowhere you
know what it is smart people never take
surveys they never get on TV so while
you get Izzy's [ __ ] Gun Owners going
like well what if the government were
over so not to be nice to me and I
needed to fight them off with their
f-16s and their tanks I needed for home
protection why okay girl at bar used my
phone to venmo herself $300 now I don't
know what venmo is but this guy
basically explains it dear Billy bass on
the wall the other night I was at this
bar with a few buddies and we started
talking to a group this group of girls
I was hitting on this one girl we talked
for a little more than an hour her
friends then said they were leaving and
so before she left I asked if I could
have her number she said yes and she
asked to my phone to put her to put in
her number or so I thought
uh-oh well she was putting in her number
I wasn't really paying attention and
started talking to my buddy next thing I
know she's handing back the phone and
saying goodbye I told her I'll text her
later this week
and try and set something up well the
next day I went to look for her number
and I couldn't find it I searched and
searched but
the number was not in my phone I was a
little disappointed but stuff like that
happens all the time
see this is why this guy gets late he
shakes it off that's right what he [ __ ]
he gonna do take another swing right a
few days later I went to venmo a
co-worker money for lunch and in my
trends in my recent transactions I see a
300 dollar payment made to that girl
from the bar
well now you got your contact info Hey
ladies what's gonna happen either you're
gonna [ __ ] me or I'm gonna get my $300
back by the way you're paying for dinner
with my money that [ __ ] took my phone
and then mowed herself 300 bucks while
pretending to give me her phone number I
gotta be honest with you if if that was
her plan the entire night and she was
nice enough to make you then ask for her
phone number that's [ __ ] amazing it's
disgusting but it's amazing he said I of
course was furious and immediately
thought of reporting her to the police
and to the people who work at venmo
but I thought nothing will get resolved
because how can I prove I didn't send
her the money and I easily tell your
story right you got to do sorry that he
said hey I think you got to do something
anyways he goes also I kind of respect
the move it's a piece of [ __ ] move but
pretty clever it is pretty goddamn
clever what would you do in this
situation I'd probably just eat the 300
bucks take it as a life lesson I never
like go after people I just don't I
don't do it I'm just like well I'm you
know I learned to [ __ ] lesson I won't
do that again he said I could try and
get the money back but do you think the
effort in the hassle outweighs the
reward I think he should do it because
it's actually a crime she stole money
from you and you know I don't know or
you just let her keep doing it and then
one day she gets caught and she [ __ ]
goes to jail because you're probably not
going to stop at this I would say you
know something considering
this whole [ __ ] new movement of just
trashing guys all the time and always
making women out to be the victim it'd
be nice a little publicity out there
that you know women have the ability to
also be pieces of [ __ ]
so yeah let's even it out a little bit I
would go after [ __ ] it
alright said three hundred dollars isn't
gonna make or break me but I do need to
stand up for guys who wouldn't be able
to pay that rent if a girl did it to
them right
any advice helps and go [ __ ] yourself
yeah I go after it the very least you
know even if you don't get your money
back just to [ __ ] it's good that you
got that information out there San Diego
fellas when somebody says I'll put my
number in your phone but you don't want
to say don't do that because then they
might be a way I'm not gonna give it to
you well you know just me I would just I
would use this guy's story I always just
say well the last time I did this the
woman took my phone and venmo Tercel
$300 out of my account so I'm just a
little paranoid so what will be give me
their number of the time yeah they do
you gonna give me my number or am I just
gonna go home and jerk off what's you
know whatever
I don't you guys figure it out I'm not
in this world anymore all right I go to
bed at like 9:30 every night now
roommate smokes weed hi Bill I really
like your podcast and really enjoyed
your show in the TAF theatre last
Saturday geez I must have good shows in
Cincy that's twice in uh three letters
first time I see I see us all a live
show and it was fantastic I have a
problem now I'm in college and my
roommate and I live on campus well that
doesn't sound like a problem it sounds
like it's [ __ ] time your life we have
our own bedroom and we we have our own
bedrooms and we don't talk very often
I'm okay with that the problem is he
might smoke weed sometimes in the
apartment he mentioned he smokes weed
the first day we moved in I never smoked
weed and I don't know what it smells
like but the smells came out of his butt
the smells that came out of his room is
not a cigarette I'm a hundred percent
sure yeah buddy that's wheat the
semester is almost over should I bring
it up with film I just get a new
roommate
he said it kind of bothered me with the
smell we only talked to once when we
moved in I don't know what to do it's
against the rule on campus should I talk
to the RA absent not dude don't talk to
the ra ra is one letter short of rat and
that's what the [ __ ] you would be don't
do don't rat them out really like your
comedy and I think I'm the only Asian
dude that went to your show thank you
and go [ __ ] yourself well thank you for
showing up and bring some of your Asian
friends with me I mean with you
to see my show unless you're the only
Asian in Cincinnati I have no idea I
don't I don't know what goes on I don't
do a census now I wouldn't rat them out
if you're really concerned about the RA
I would just say hey buddy I don't give
a [ __ ] that you smoke weed actually I do
care that you smoke weed but I'm not a
rat so I'm not gonna say anything to the
RA but it is illegal and I'm concerned
that how much I can smell it the RA is
gonna smell it and then I'm gonna get in
trouble - all right can you do a better
job of blowing it out the window or
stick a thicker towel underneath the
door all right that's it I swear to God
I won't talk to you again man that sucks
man you guys don't even talk to each
other so the first day you came there
and you were just like I don't smoke
weed and this guy's just like well I'm
[ __ ] done with you
everybody thinks pot smokers are cool I
don't know this guy sounds like a [ __ ]
neighbor drove through my fence hey
Billy belligerent the title sums up this
email but I feel like I'm in a bit of a
situation I recently moved back into my
childhood home after being away for
about four years unfortunately my dad
passed away I'm sorry to hear that
but he left me the house that he paid
off in full nice how the hell did he do
that usually the they hit you with so
many penalties and fees that you have to
put the house back into play he said the
house itself is it disrepair oh well
there you go leaky roof bad septic lines
etc so I already have a lot to take care
of
in the coming months yesterday my
neighbor and childhood friend got
shit-faced and drove his new truck
through my fence thank god this is some
[ __ ] redneck [ __ ]
and got into and into the giant oak tree
in my front yard the fence is wire so it
was salvaged salvageable I need to go to
that pronunciation video Sal salvaged
salvageable salvageable salvageable
salvageable there it is but I thought I
was still pissed my other neighbor has
security footage of the whole event dude
is everybody filming everybody now can
you get away with anything including the
hilarious moment when the guy when he
tried to pull it back but I guess the
fence and fell on his ass against all my
neighbors advice I didn't end up
pressing charges although my brother who
lives with me as well did file a police
report which is now on the drunk
neighbors record my question is did I do
the right thing by not pressing charges
and sending him to jail well how would
you send him to jail I mean by the time
you got the footage he would be sober
and he could just say ah you know I was
looking down at my phone on my back
itched and I took my hand off the wheel
I'm more or less cut ties with this guy
because he's a volatile person as
evidenced by this whole situation he has
two young children one in three I think
recently lost his job and has a lot to
deal with so I didn't want to [ __ ] him
over even more and he did actually fix
my fence when he sobered up however I I
don't think this will be the last time
something stupid like this happens
should I have sent his ass to jail or
did I do the right thing I mean I
wouldn't have said anything the fact
that he got up the next day and he tried
to [ __ ] fix the fence I would talk to
him about it say hey listen man you know
I don't want to get into your business
or anything like that but I love getting
shit-faced too but if there's any way
you could over next time you know
because if I was walking up the driveway
you know you would have run over me you
know I don't mind getting hammered or
whatever but that level I hammered and
then to drive his a little [ __ ] crazy
how's everything going with the job
hunting ask him a couple of nice [ __ ]
questions
and say listen I really appreciate that
the next day you woke up he did the
right thing and you fix the fence all
right now that's what I would say too
okay and then on the other hand I think
the fence issue you need to look no
further than the story of the three
little pigs
all right the wolf went to the first
house little pig little pig let me in
and the pig goes yeah I don't feel
comfortable with that dude
and he said I well then I'm just gonna
blow this piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] house
over and that's exactly what he did but
he's a little light-headed and the pig
gets away he runs over to the [ __ ]
his other brother's house you know who
actually went to college you know but
just got a degree in philosophy so all
he could afford was a house made out of
sticks
the wolf shows up he's like egg he
little fatty
open this door when little pig little
pig let me in and then the pig goes yeah
man you know my other brother you know
who took shop class he just blew his
[ __ ] house down he took shop class
before somehow he lives in a [ __ ]
house made out of hay I'm not [ __ ]
doing this site blows that one down and
then they go to his you know the guy who
made it in finance
he stole a bunch of [ __ ] money he's
got a brick house he's gotta break my
banner
bird and he's my two fat [ __ ] over
old people you need that you need to put
up a brick wall
oh man that will piss him off somebody
did that then the next thing you put up
a [ __ ] brick wall and then if he
gives you [ __ ] just put your hands out
like what you drove through the other
one you you're gonna [ __ ] run me over
one night go hit this poor tree what
about the tree the tree can't sue you
it's a victim of [ __ ] drinking and
driving
you can't take you to court they can
file a complaint but I can't get there
it's stuck in the ground then you got a
little brick wall between the two hey
buddy if you weren't such a [ __ ]
drunk you know I wouldn't have to do
this other than that what are you gonna
do I would have my head on a swivel
though when I got into my [ __ ]
driveway this is the deal
I would just tell the guy just said
listen man I'm not I don't want I don't
want to call the cops I don't want to do
any [ __ ] like that
all right but if it happens again I'm
gonna have to because you're gonna kill
somebody all right
I don't please don't put me in that
position that's what I would say and
then I would build a brick wall although
I think I would deal with my set m'q
tank first but you know what you can't
take a [ __ ] if you're dead this is do
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna make
you put the priorities up there you're
gonna roll the dice that this [ __ ]
crazy [ __ ] in his trunk and
trucks gonna come over there drop your
[ __ ] wire fence I think you need an
air 15 to shoot out his [ __ ] tires as
he comes towards your oak tree why don't
you talk to the [ __ ] cheese how cool
is that that guy he owns a farm and he
makes cheese you know what I mean so
rare do you meet somebody that actually
has a job now that it's like wow we
really need that we need that guy that
we need you making another [ __ ] app
that can have some hordes steal $300
from you oh it's so easy and convenient
that some of you don't even know can
just send them [ __ ] money hey
wouldn't you have her number from the
transaction I'd call her up give me my
300 bucks back you [ __ ] thievin [ __ ]
before I call the cops
I get my 300 bucks back and then I would
call the cops there you go that's what I
would do with her at the fence thing
yeah how am i right with that but I
would tell them not to do it again all
right okay that's the podcast have a
great couple of days you go [ __ ]
yourselves and I'll check on Thursday